As you touched upon this off when you
talked about how a like means nothing,
but if a like cost you 10 bucks, it
might begin to mean something.
Um, a repost costing
a gadget could actually be a real value
signal that people can follow these
things. And and this is where all of the
things that we've talked about so many
times over the years around what is
corporatism, what is capitalism, you're
seeing the break that's going to make
all of this come into fruition. That
this is the real economy. This is the
unbridled capitalist economy. This is
the one that everybody can be part of
and the price signals drive events.
As it should be. That's that's the
efficiency model that we've always
talked